- - C'est la course
cocontre la montre avant l'arrie
dede randonneurs en vacances. Ns
sosommes en juin. Les violentes
inintempéries de mai ont déracié
dedes milliers d'arbres dans
LaLanaudière et les Laurentides.
- - Non, il est bien pognéné!
- - Objectif : couper les arbres
momorts qui pourraient s'abattre
susur des randonneurs
etet dégager le sentier.
- - Les arbres ne tomberont pas
apaprès notre passage.
- - Nous sommes sur le territoie
dede la Sépaq, près de l'entréee
lala réserve faunique Mastigouc,
auau nord de Mandeville.
LeLe sentier que Réal Martel
etet ses bénévoles sécurisent me
auau Sentier national du Québec.
- - 500 mètres.
- - Oui.
- - En canot?
- - Non, à pied.
- - À l'accueil de la Sépaq,
onon explique notamment aux
rarandonneurs comment s'y rendr.
MAMANON BEAUSOLEIL,
prpréposée à l'accueil, Sépaq
- - C'est pas entretenu
papar la Sépaq, alors
c'c'est vraiment des bénévoles
dudu Sentier national qui viennt
enentretenir les sentiers.
- - Est-ce qu'ils sont importan,
ceces bénévoles-là?
- - Oui, ils sont importants!
C'C'est sûr que les randonneurs
leles apprécient beaucoup.
- - Le Sentier national
a a d'ailleurs été fondé
papar un bénévole, nul autre que
RéRéal Martel.
RERÉAL MARTEL, fondateur
dudu Sentier national du Québec
- - On a une belle forêt
auau Québec. Pourquoi on aurait
papas notre propre sentier? Alos
enen 89, j'ai sorti mes cartes
etet puis j'ai dessiné un sentir
ququi traverserait la province.
- - Ce parcours de 1650 kilomèts
s's'échelonne désormais de
l'l'Outaouais jusqu'en Gaspésie.
- - Bonjour!
- - Ah! Des bénévoles.
- - Ça adonne comme ça, ou...?
- - C'est un hasard.
- - Êtes-vous sérieux?
- - C'est en plein ça!
- - Ah! oui? Enchanté, enchanté!
- - Du renfort pour Réal Martet.
CeCe groupe arrive de
SaSaint-Alexis-des-Monts.
LeLeur chef d'équipe est
reresponsable d'un autre tronço.
- - La plupart des gestionnaires
enen ont ici avec tous les arbrs
totombés.
- - La Sépaq gère 1450 kilomètrs
susur 17 000 kilomètres de
sesentiers québécois. Les
mumunicipalités et les MRC fontn
bobout de chemin, mais chez Rano
QuQuébec, on est catégoriques :
c'c'est le milieu communautaire
ququi fait presque tout.
GRGRÉGORY FLAYOL, directeur
gégénéral adjoint, Rando Q Québc
- - La majajorité des réseaux de
sesentiers, c'est administré par
dedes organismes sans but lucraf
etet par des bénévoles. Donc
ilils amènent tout leur matérie,
ilils achètent des outils.
- - À la suite des violentes
inintempéries, Rando Québec
a a demandé une aide financière
exexceptionnelle d'urgence de 10
00000 $ pour aider les bénévole.
L La demande d'aide financièree
RaRando Québec a tourné en ronde
miministère en ministère, de
fofonctionnaire en fonctionnair.
L'L'organisme a finalement essué
unun refus à la mi-juin
sosous p prétexte qu'aucun proge
n'n'existe pour financer
l'l'entretien des sentiers,
etet donc qu'il n'y aura pas
dede financement.
- - Puis le dessous, quand il la
acaccroché, il a fait ça,
alalors il il a débarqué de son.
dede sa roulette.
- - Du financement qui aurait
nonotamment permis d'acheter de
nonouvelles scies mécaniques.
RéRéal devra réparer la sienne
dedeux fois durant notre tourna.
- - Oh boy...
- - Le fondateur du Sentier
nanational dit ne pas s comprene
lele gouvernement.
- - C'est qu'il a pas compris qe
c'c'est pour la santé des gens
auaussi qu'on fait ça.
LeLes touristes... Les touristes
pupuis la santé sont gagnants.
- - Le gouvernement Legault
a a appelé à plusieurs reprises
leles Québécois à profiter de
lala nature durant la pandémie.
DrDr HORACIO ARRUDA, dir. nat. e
sasanté publique du Qc (201212-)
- - Quand vous êtes tout seul,
vovous allez prendre une belle
mamarche dans la forêt,t, ça va
vovous calmer, vous allez prende
dede l'air, il fait beau.
- - Les gens ont tendance à penr
ququ'un sentier de randonnée,
çaça se fait tout seul.
C'C'est pas le cas.
C'C'est énormément de travail.
CLCLAUDE CORMIER, bénévole et
prprésident de la Nature d'Alexs
- - Je trouve ça aberrant quand
ilils donnent bien de l'argent x
auautres fédérations sportives.
- - Le ministère des Transports
a a injecté 15 millions $ dans s
progogrammes voués spécifiquemet
àà l'entretien et la sécurité
dedes sentiers de motoneige,
dede véhicules tout-terrain
etet de moto hors route en 2022.
R Radio-Canada a interpellé
plplusieurs ministères.
AuAucun progogramme similaire dé
auau fininancement des sentiers
pépédestres n'existe.
EtEt le gouvernement Legault
coconfirme ne pas avoir
l'l'intention d'en créer un.
- - C'est toujours les mêmes
bébénévoles qui sont là.
MaMais aujourd'hui, ils sont
vivieillissants ces gens-là.
- - Facteur à la retraite,
RéRéal Martel, père de
ququatre enfants et grand-père
dede six petits-enfants, n'est s
unun homme de mots, mais d'acti.
- - Le site est sécurisé
mamaintenant.
- - Il ne le dira jamais dans
ceces mots-là, mais le Sentier
nanational est le projet d'une e
popour lui. Il espère qu'il viva
auaussi après lui.
I Ici Julie Marceau,
R Radio-Canada, dans la réserve
f faunique Mastigouch